Some people say he's not fat.
didn't drink
Why does fatty liver occur?
How would I know?
Há(transliteration)
You're a doctor, you don't know?
Do you think being thin guarantees safety?
wrong
Fatty liver disease is most likely
to affect people aged 40 to 69
I am over 70 years old this year.
So it's okay
There is a type of coffee
It can protect the liver.
Reduce the risk of fatty liver
I'll tell you right away
Hu Naiwen is about to begin his lecture.
I am your old friend, Dr. Hu.
Half of Taiwan's population has fatty liver disease.
One type of coffee reduces risk
Do you know how many people in Taiwan
have fatty liver disease?
According to the Liver Disease Prevention and Treatment Academic Foundation
The 2024 survey said
53.3% probability
What does this mean?
Did you know?
If the two of us stand here
will one of us
That's right, that's the odds of winning.
Much easier than winning 200 New Taiwan dollars
in the receipt lottery
Don't think that fatty liver is unimportant
just because it doesn't cause pain
You're ignoring your fatty liver
It may also evolve into
Liver cirrhosis and liver cancer
This is no joke.
That's serious!
So, for us healthy people...
How to avoid fatty liver?
You are like me.
Coffee lovers are in for a treat!
This cup of black coffee
It can protect the liver.
Research findings say
Black coffee can reduce the risk of fatty liver
by 23%
Even the risk of liver cancer
can be reduced by 40%.
Then I'll just drink five cups a day.
The more you drink, the better
Is that right?
No, that's not it.
Two to three cups a day is fine, okay?
In coffee
Add two spoonfuls of sugar
and milk
Is this effective?
Drinking for a sense of happiness is certainly possible.
However, to reduce fatty liver...
It's best not to.
What truly protects the liver
Black coffee
You added too much sugar
and creamer
It's not just a matter of reduced effectiveness.
It will also increase the burden on the liver.
Why black coffee
It can reduce fatty liver.
Because black coffee contains
Contains caffeine and polyphenols
It can promote the breakdown of fat in the liver.
Reduce fat accumulation in the liver
Reduce inflammation
Improve liver metabolic function
People with fatty liver
You could try drinking black coffee
regularly
For example, one cup a day
Help the liver reduce fat
It can also reduce inflammation.
Patting your calves helps regulate liver qi.
Sleep aid and prevent fatty liver
Have you been experiencing any of these symptoms lately?
Shoulders stiff
can't sleep well at night
Often there
Ouch
Seeing you like this
Is your liver meridian not flowing smoothly?
Oh,
how did you figure that out?
The liver is responsible for the smooth flow of Qi and blood throughout the body.
If the liver qi is blocked, the qi cannot flow smoothly.
Your shoulders and neck
start to stiffen
Irritable
Poor sleep
Liver Qi stagnation
Over time
The most troublesome thing
is that fat will start to get stuck
in the liver
Many people believe
Fatty liver is related to eating too much oil.
Actually, a slower metabolism
is the real reason why people suffer from fatty liver.
Unblock liver qi
The simplest way is
Patting the liver meridian
Regularly pat this meridian
Helps to soothe the liver and regulate qi
It can also relax the autonomic nervous system.
Then anxiety and irritability
will be reduced
How to tap the liver meridian
It's very simple.
You use a cupped hand
From the inner thigh
tap of the inside of the calf.
tap from above
You spend 3 minutes every day
No need to spend a penny
Pat the liver meridian
It can be obtained
Relax shoulders and get a good night's sleep.
When liver qi flows smoothly
The body's metabolism will speed up
For people who want to improve fatty liver
A good auxiliary method
Yay! Spring is almost here!
When we are watching TV series
Come and pat liver meridian.
can also pat it before bed.
Springtime is the best time to nourish the liver.
It's not just about eating too much oil.
3 Causes of Fatty Liver
Do you think fatty liver
is caused by eating too much oily food
Things aren't as foolish as people think.
Fatty liver will come for you
It's usually a reminder to you
Your metabolism can't keep up.
What causes fatty liver?
There are three main culprits that cause fatty liver.
1. Eating too much refined food
2. Obesity
3. Metabolic abnormalities
aLet's start with the first one.
Fatty liver in many people
Because of refined carbohydrates and sugar
Eat too much
You often have regular meals
all eat noodles
Pair it with a hand-shaken beverage
Afternoon tea with cake
Eating too much fruit
You heard me right
It can also accumulate sugar in the liver.
Turn into fat
After these sugars enter the bloodstream...
Blood sugar will rise
Insulin secretion will increase accordingly.
The liver will convert excess sugar into fat
for storage
Over time, it can easily lead to fatty liver.
How to get rid of fatty liver
You must reduce the sugar content first.
Reduce sugar
Eat less cake and sweets
People who used to drink 5 cups of bubble tea a week
For now, switch to drinking 4 cups per week.
The other cup was changed to unsweetened tea.
Or black coffee would be even better.
People with fatty liver
What fruits are edible?
Apples, pears, blueberries, strawberries, and cranberries taste good.
Fruits with firm flesh
It is high in dietary fiber
Blood sugar is not easy to spike
Berries are low in sugar
Strong antioxidant
It helps with liver repair.
The second culprit: obesity.
The third culprit is metabolic abnormalities.
If you have metabolic problems
For example, issues related to blood sugar, blood lipids, and blood pressure.
The liver is prone to fatigue.
Fat accumulates in the liver
Fatty liver
Even more terrifying is
Fatty liver disease slows down
the liver's response to insulin
This makes blood sugar rise more easily.
Over time it will cause
Hepatitis, cirrhosis
It also increases the risk of developing diabetes.
How to eliminate these two types of fatty liver?
First, change your diet
What foods can help eliminate fatty liver?
The first is high-fiber vegetables.
Spinach, Chinese kale, sweet potato leaves, cauliflower
Helps the liver metabolize fat
Maintain stable blood sugar
Second protein
Chicken breast, tofu, salmon
Pacific saury, tuna, eggs
Prevent fat from accumulating in the liver
Promotes liver repair
Third, eat good oil
You use olive oil, eat nuts
Reduce saturated fatty acids
This can
adjust body fat
Improve fatty liver
Let's talk about sports.
Don't sit for long periods of time at work
If can take the stairs, don't take the elevator.
Have a full meal after get off work
Come and jog!
Open my super slow jogging video.
Run for 10 minutes to half an hour
stable blood sugar
weight will definitely go down.
Buy 6 kinds of vegetables for stir-frying and soup making
Eliminate all toxins
The liver is busy every day processing toxins
in the body
If too much accumulates
This can easily affect health.
So how to quickly detoxify the liver?
Add 6 kinds of vegetables
to your plate
Cabbage, cauliflower, white radish
Garlic, onion, kelp
Enhance liver detoxification function
Type 1: Cabbage, Cauliflower, White Radish
They are all small vanguard members
of the Brassicaceae family
Contains natural compounds
It can help
Liver cells enhance detoxification function
Just a reminder
raw cabbage
can't eat too much!
There may be a problem with goiter.
The second type is garlic and onion.
They are all sulfur-containing foods.
Sulfur is an essential component for liver detoxification.
It is very helpful
in removing heavy metals and food additives
The third type of kelp
They have natural minerals
Good for the liver
It can prevent heavy metals from being absorbed by the body.
Reduce the burden on the liver
Our mothers and grandmothers
You can make seaweed miso soup.
You can also make kelp and pork rib soup.
It can help everyone
The whole family should regulate their liver qi.
You should eat a bowl too!
Add one type of bean to fish soup
Reduce edema and reverse liver disease
Tell you how
I know I have liver disease.
The doctor will tell you
These 6 signs
How to tell if a person's liver
is having problems
1. Jaundice
2. Abdominal swelling
3. Edema
4. Itchy skin
5. Urine color darkens
6. The color of the feces turns white
Let me tell you about a patient with liver disease.
A while ago
A woman in her sixties came to see me.
Her liver
There's already a problem. It's very bad.
It has reached what Western medicine calls
The degree of liver cancer and cirrhosis.
His complexion was yellowish and had a blackish tinge.
And there is also ascites.
It looked really scary back then.
Perhaps days on earth are numbered.
Oh, that sounds serious.
Oh, did you manage to save her?
I prescribed her traditional Chinese medicine
to lì shuǐ tuì huáng ((transliteration))
Please ask her to go back and cook a soup.
Oh, what kind of soup?
Using food to heal illnesses
It's red bean and carp soup.
It's red beans and carp
Cook together
How long did you eat it?
After eating it for about two or three weeks
Her ascites gradually subsided.
complexion also began to improve.
started to laugh.
spirits are also better.
Oh, that sounds amazing!
You're awesome too!
This carp and red bean soup
It comes from ancient books.
It records that red beans
also known as red beans, are used.
Cook adzuki beans and carp into a broth to eat
It can reduce edema and is also good for cooking porridge.
She can cook porridge, that's fine too.
This carp and red bean soup
How to do it?
Prepare 50 grams of red beans.
1 carp
Of course, it's not easy to buy carp.
That's if it's possible to buy it.
Okay, wash the red beans clean.
Clean the carp by removing its scales and innards.
Add water, scallions, ginger, and salt, like this.
But use less salt!
Or you can omit the salt.
Just stew it until it's cooked.
This soup...
It has the effect of qīng rè jiě dú (transliteration)
Diuretic and swelling-reducing effects
Suitable for people with edema
I remember a patient
from before
His hands were swollen.
feet are swollen too.
Drank for a period of time
About a month
The swelling has gone down.
Even edema after chemotherapy
They are all very effective.